THE UKRAINIAN FOREIGN MINISTRY
WARNING IF RUSSIA CONTINUES THE
WAR, CHERNOBYL CAN HAPPEN AGAIN
IN 2022.
JOINING US LIVE FROM KYIV,
MATTHEW CHANCE.
MATTHEW, YOU AND YOUR TEAM
EXCLUSIVELY WITNESSED A
CONFRONTATION TODAY AT AN
AIRFIELD OUTSIDE KYIV.
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED AND WHAT
IT TELLS YOU ABOUT UKRAINE'S
CHANCES OF KEEPING CONTROL OF
ITS OWN CAPITAL.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
I MEAN IT WAS ASTONISHING BUT IT
WAS UNEXPECTED AS WELL.
WE WERE MAKING OUR WAY TO AN
AIRFIELD NEAR THE CAPITAL OF
KYIV THAT HAD BEEN ATTACKED.
WE KNEW THERE HAD BEEN FIGHTING
THERE OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PREVIOUS HOURS.
IT'S AN ESSENTIAL AIR BASE THAT
THE RUSSIAN SPECIAL FORCES WE
UNDERSTOOD HAD BEEN DROPPED
THERE TO SEIZE IN ORDER TO
ESTABLISH A BRIDGE SO THEY COULD
BRING IN MORE FORCES.
WE WENT THERE.
THERE WAS A CHECKPOINT AT THE
GATES.
I WAS TOLD MY UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS THAT THE UKRAINIANS
HAD IT BACK UNDER CONTROL AFTER
FIERCE FIGHTING.
I SPENT SOME TIME TALKING WITH
THE SOLDIERS OUTSIDE SAYING WHO
IS IT THAT'S IN CONTROL RIGHT
NOW I SAID TO THE COMMANDING
OFFICER IN MY BROKEN RUSSIAN.
HE SAID IT'S THE RUSSIANS THAT
ARE IN CONTROL.
I SAID, OKAY, SO WHERE ARE THE
RUSSIANS THEN?
AND HE SAID WE'RE THE RUSSIANS.
WHICH WAS INCREDIBLE BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT THEY WERE UKRAINIAN
FORCES.
I LOOKED AT THEIR INSIGNIA AND
WE HAD ENCOUNTERIED THAT FOREIG
GROUP OF RUSSIAN SPECIAL FORCES
THAT HAD ENGAGED IN FIERCE
FIGHTING AND WERE NOW FACING A
COUNTERATTACK FROM THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY.
AT THAT POINT WE STEPPED AWAY
AND WITNESSED THIS
.
>> LET'S MOVE DOWN THIS WAY
AGAINST THE WALL.
IT'S OKAY, IT'S OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WELL, THAT WAS A VERY DRAMATIC
OUTBURST THERE.
GUNFIRE AND AN ENEMY WE DIDN'T
SEE.
WE ASSUME IT WAS SOME KIND OF
THREAT THAT THEY FELT FROM
PERHAPS COUNTEROFFENSES.
I'VE BEEN TOLD BY UKRAINE
OFFICIALS THERE WAS A
COUNTEROFFENSIVE ON THE WAY JUST
BEFORE WE GOT THERE.
REMEMBER, THAT AIR BASE IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL IF RUSSIAN
FORCES ARE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
BRIDGE HEAD TO BRING IN MORE
TROOPS, MORE EQUIPMENT TO
ENCIRCLE THE CAPITAL AND
POTENTIALLY TAKE THE ENTIRE CITY
OF KYIV AND TAKE IT OVER, JAKE.
>> MATTHEW, EARLIER TODAY YOU
CALLED THE IDEA OF A MILITARY
CONFRONTATION BETWEEN THE
RUSSIANS AND UKRAINIANS NEAR THE
CHERNOBYL NUCLEAR EXCLUSION
ZONE, YOU CALLED IT QUITE,
FRANKLY, TERRIFYING OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF ALL THE UNKNOWNS
ABOUT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN IF THAT
RADIOACTIVE MATERIAL WERE
DISTURBED.
DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA WHY RUSSIA
MIGHT WANT CONTROL OF CHERNOBYL?
IS IT JUST ANOTHER PIECE OF
TERRITORY OR IS THERE SOMETHING
MORE TO IT THAN THAT?
>> Reporter: I'VE BEEN THEY
THINKING ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT
AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY.
BUT THE OBVIOUS ANSWER IS THE
GEOGRAPHICAL LOCATION OF IT.
IT'S NOT FAR FROM KYIV BUT IT'S
ALSO ON THE BORDER OF BELARUS SO
IT'S A BIT OF OPEN TERRITORY
WHICH EVEN THOUGH IT'S
CONTAMINATED TERRIBLY OF COURSE
STILL WITH RADIOACTIVE MATERIAL,
IT IS TERRITORY THAT GIVES
ACCESS TO UKRAINE FROM THE
NORTH, FROM BELARUS.
THERE WAS ALSO A LOT OF
SPECULATION IN THE RUSSIAN MEDIA
PARTICULARLY BEFORE THIS
INVASION HAPPENED THAT CHERNOBYL
COULD BE A POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS
PLACE WHERE ANT ECOLOGICAL
DISASTER COULD BE SPARKED.
UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN EXPRESSING
THEIR CONCERN ABOUT THAT AS
WELL.
THAT'S WHY I SAID IT WAS SO
TERRIFYING THAT IT'S A
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS MILITARY
CONFRONTATION AROUND THAT
NUCLEAR REACTOR, WHICH IS
CURRENTLY HOUSED IN A
SARCOPHAGUS MADE OUT OF CONCRETE
TO TRY TO LIMIT ANY FURTHER
DAMAGE THAT COULD BE CAUSED BY
IT.
OF COURSE IF IT DOES BECOME THE
FOCUS OF A STRONG MILITARY
CONFRONTATION BETWEEN THESE TWO
ARMIES, THAT COULD KICK UP ALL
SORTS OF HORRIFIC RADIOACTIVE
MATERIAL AND, YOU KNOW, CAUSE
TH